welcome everybody to Long crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber Megan the stallion
testified in court that fellow rapper
Tory Lanez offered her 1 million dollars
to not report him to police for
allegedly shooting her but the woman who
Lane says was the actual shooter may
have just thrown a wrench in the case
with her testimony or maybe I should say
lack thereof now Megan the stallion was
in a Los Angeles courtroom Tuesday as
part of the assault trial against Lanes
the prosecution maintains that Megan
lanes and Megan's former friend Kelsey
Harris were in a car after a
get-together at Kylie Jenner's house
when there was some sort of argument
when she got out of the car Megan
claimed she heard Lane's tell her to
dance and saw the gun in his hand either
bullets or shrapnel hit her in the foot
on the stand the Megan was emotional
saying that the aftermath of the
shooting included backlash against her
on social media and from the rap
industry and that this has been very
difficult for her now on the other side
lane says it was actually Kelsey who
fired the gun and he's being set up but
in a new twist Kelsey was given immunity
by prosecutors after invoking her Fifth
Amendment right while on the stand and
during her testimony she decided not to
answer crucial questions about the case
so I want to bring in my co-host and
defense attorney Brian buckmeyer Brian
this is all just happened before the
lunch break in the west coast case what
is going on right now Jesse Kelsey
Harris was asked when Tory threatened to
shoot you exactly what did Tori say but
she wouldn't answer instead pleading the
fifth multiple times before the judge
led the jury out to go for lunch
pleading the fifth is everyone's right
and Kelsey Harris is welcome to use it
without it being held against her
especially considering she has immunity
but it can be used as evidence or lack
thereof in asking whether or not Tory
Lanez is guilty of the crimes he is
charged with and this does not look good
for the prosecution if Harris is
pleading the fifth and the judge is
allowing it then Harris's attorney must
have been able to explain to the judge
that there's some potential crime that
she could be admitting to now she has
immunity which was given to her pretty
easily that might explain something to
the jury but this is their star witness
and it looks like it's falling apart
yeah let me bring in coast and former
trial Attorney Terry Austin on this so
Terry based on what we've heard so far
what's your theory about who actually
shot Megan this down there shot at Megan
the stallion you know at first I really
thought it was Tory Lanez
and she has immunity and yet she's not
saying whether it was she who shot that
gun so it's unclear to me whether or not
Lane shot the gun whether or not Kelsey
shot the gun and if she really does want
to protect herself then she is protected
with this immunity agreement she can go
ahead and say look it was me I did it
but she is not saying that so I'm a
little bit confused at this point I'm
not sure I think we have to see more
evidence and in fact I think no matter
what anybody says whose gun was that and
whose bullet was it
I thought the whole case itself had a
lot of drama who knew that this was
going to happen in a courtroom it's just
an unpredictable complicated aspect
about it I should tell you this case
which has been more than two years in
the making is getting a lot of attention
on social media especially among
journalists music journalists and fans
people came out to the courthouse to
show their support for Megan the
stallion
it's not right and it's unfortunate
because there is no perfect victim per
se at the end of the day if you are a
strong person and you have a voice and
you stand up for yourself and you stand
up for your boundaries
your villainized
so our job is to stand with survivors we
are here to make sure that survivors
know that they have a voice they have an
opportunity to come forward and it's
really scary to do so
all right so this is a case that's going
to leave people divided we move now to
an update for you in Moscow Idaho a gas
station attendant may have spotted the
white car the police have been looking
for in connection to a quadruple
stabbing the clerk gave this still image
to Fox News saying that she had some
down time during her shift so she looked
at surveillance video from the store's
cameras from November 13th now that is
the night that Ford University of Idaho
students sleeping in the same home were
stabbed to death police put out the call
that they were looking for a white
Hyundai Elantra because the person might
have seen something important many
people from parents to students to
online amateur sleuths are demanding
more answers from Moscow police but a
former homicide detective that we spoke
to says this is just how investigations
work
in terms of of how far they is
progressed in that investigation there
are so many aspects of that that we
don't know
and there are so many aspects of it that
we don't at this point when I say we
talking about the general public of
course don't need to know we don't need
to know those things because they may
inadvertently
compromise the Integrity of that
investigation and I know that's kind of
the the typical response when
any agency is is just mercilessly beaten
up with questions about where are you
what are you doing what have you done
and that kind of thing but that is the
proper response uh it's a it becomes a
problem because we live in a in a fast
food world
and we expect those things to happen in
that manner and the reality is is that
these cases don't get solved in
43 minutes with no commercials that's a
good point just don't know if it's going
to temper people's frustrations or
answers well Tuesday marked one month
since the murders in Moscow police
leadership have been very candid at
times with the public and police Captain
Roger Lanier took the opportunity to
share what he heard and saw when he
first got to the scene the scene wasn't
chaos you know the neighborhood but it
was very very somber
like I said that is a community of
college students that live over there
many of them through Word of Mouth knew
what had happened they were standing
outside there was a lot of crying there
were friends trying to find out who
exactly was inside the house some family
members that arrived on scene was
incredibly hard for the community but it
was also really really hard on our
officers some of whom were very young
and that was uh the first real major
crime scene that they had encountered so
emotionally it was a very very draining
day well nfts are back in the spotlight
thanks to a class action lawsuit filed
against Yuga Labs it's a cryptocurrency
startup and also dozens of A-list
celebrities the plaintiff's alleged that
Superstars like Justin Bieber Madonna
Jimmy Fallon and Kevin Hart all promoted
the company's board ape Yacht Club it's
a collection of online art that features
well you guessed it forward-looking Apes
now what are the big selling points for
the board eight biak Club was that it
was very exclusive and that multiple
celebrities are members too but the
lawsuit says dozens of celebrities
promoted the digital assets generating
billions of dollars in sales and resales
of nfts without revealing that Yuga Labs
was paying them for their endorsement so
we asked an internet and Technology
attorney who's to blame in this kind of
situation
when a celebrity is being brought on as
an ambassador or as somebody who's going
to be endorsing a product or service of
course they have to do their due
diligence but at the same time it's also
the companies that are bringing them on
they have to be transparent about hey
we're bringing on this person and yes we
are paying them and hopefully the
celebrity the talent is being honest
with their Community right about hey
look we are getting paid to promote this
and hopefully within that they
understand what it is that they're
promoting
Terry we've got some really big name
celebrities here with many of us living
so much of our Lives online civil cases
like this really could become more
common right oh absolutely I think we
are going to see a lot more cases like
this look everyone is buying and selling
products online
nfts are becoming more and more popular
because of that nft actually stands for
non-fungible token it turns your online
asset into an exclusive product with a
unique digital code that verifies the
asset and traces every single
transaction involving that asset it's
similar to a patent given by the U.S
patent and trademark office in this case
the nfts were used to certify the board
of ape artwork no one's claiming that
the artwork is not real essentially what
the plaintiffs are claiming here is that
the value of the artwork was inflated by
the celebrity endorsements who first of
all knew nothing about the product and
who did not invest in the product and
who basically failed to fully disclose
any payments that they got because they
endorsed it you know we also asked our
expert if celebrities will now think
twice about giving these types of
endorsements he said absolutely they're
going to think twice about it because
they don't want to get sued you know
what the bottom line is that everyone
whether you're a celebrity or not you
have to do your due diligence you have
to be more careful before you and buy or
endorse any product Terry I will tell
you that is the best explanation I've
heard about what an nft is because I'm I
was still confused it was what it was
Brian how bad is this looking for
celebrities being sued for promoting
crypto yeah Jesse first this is the
first time I've understood nfts since it
first came out but looking at some of
the celebrities who are sued in the past
Kim Kardashian actually just won a
similar case with erytheon Max because
the plaintiff in the case couldn't prove
that individuals actually watched the
commercials attached to these nfts in
order to actually have them buy more so
while it might seem pretty
straightforward did you promote this nft
without giving this disclaimer there
does seem to be some wiggle room in
terms of litigation here where there may
be arguments that could be made to say
hey I wasn't a direct influence you were
influenced by this you don't know
whether or not you saw my commercial or
you haven't pled so in the urethra Max
case they might repeat that case and
come forward again but there does seem
to be Lighting in the tunnel for some of
these cases nfts SPF FTX has anybody
wondering why we're all confused ah
Terry Bryan thanks so much as always
everyone out there thanks for joining us
here on Long crime daily we will see you
next time as we discuss Justice in
America
thank you